the Joe Rogan experience do you see the
Phil Hartman documentary no that was
interesting I didn't know a lot of it
they really uh really you're in it a
little bit I didn't know a lot of things
one thing I didn't know is how they gave
you a part in the show where it was
supposed to be Phil's character writing
you or something like that like a will
or something and they gave it to each
person in the cast and they didn't let
you read it beforehand
so that when you were reading it in the
show it was actually your first time
reading like this letter that was
supposed to be from Phil yeah and I
didn't know that I was amazing
yeah that was that was one of the
weirdest moments of my life you know
getting phone calls that he was dead my
phone just kept ringing people just kept
calling and friends and loved ones and
family members and it was just it didn't
seem real like who would kill that guy
he was the nicest guy I wish you hadn't
met him yeah he was so cool like you
[ __ ] everybody like that guy and he
used to like to get high and go to strip
clubs yeah he's like get high and go to
strip clubs get high and ride around his
boat I went to a strip club with him do
you remember which one
um I think it was Bob's classy lady I
think that's what it was called I don't
think it's around anymore but he had an
appreciation for these young ladies that
was like it was it was almost childlike
but it wasn't creepy he was like god
you're beautiful
he'll look at me cuz he was high he was
like look amazing this is incredible
like he was having a good time
he was it he was a really really unique
character I remember there was a guy who
was some guy was blackmailing him and
some guy had filmed him at a strip club
with his wife and his wife was getting a
lap dance and he was getting a lap dance
too and the guy was like he wrote some
really creepy letter saying that this is
gonna violate the policies cuz you know
Phil it had endorsements and commercial
deels and who's doing movies and stuff
like that was just blowing up got it
Ferrari
you know he's blowing up and this guy uh
went to his house and nailed this VHS
tape in an envelope to his garage door
and I was with him on on a phone call so
it feels like I'm gonna talk to him
right now I'm gonna come come come come
in my room
so I went in his dressing room and the
guy calls me like hey what's going on
buddy he was talking to the kinda like
the guy was his friend and they were
setting the guy up and you know Phil's
gonna give him like I don't forget what
the money was tens of thousands of
dollars meet me at this place and I'll
meet you there
and he had these for lack of a better
term he had someone who's a dangerous
person meet this guy and let him know in
no uncertain terms that his life is
gonna take a terrible turn for the worst
if he continued down this path and but
it was uh it was weird to see like
someone trying to exploit him and the
guy was so dumb he actually met with
Phil like Phil knew who the guy was like
he saw his face you know I was there
with the guy was like look you know I
just need some money and feels like I
get it so big deal no it's just it's
weird when you see someone trying to
like prey on like they think that's
their way out like this is my way out
I'm just gonna get this guy to give me
some money and I'm gonna put it all
together you get it fell I mean that
just needs some money he's like I get it
buddy no big deal I was just playing
this guy along until the dangerous men
came and talked to him Wow
they also really focused a lot on the
wife which I didn't really know much
about about how she wanted to be an
actress also I mean like she was trying
to get Phil to like put her into shows
and doing that you know and stuff like
that and she was very resentful of him
yeah she would insult him like insult
him publicly like oh it was just really
gross sad but he didn't think he should
get divorced because he felt like it was
bad for his image he was like really
concerned about his image because he was
like this squeaky
family guy who was you know I mean it
was really starting to take off for him
see Phil didn't really make it until he
was older in life like I don't think he
was I don't think he got on Sara alive
until he was in his late late 30s might
have been older than that and when he
was on Newsradio I think he was like 46
yeah
so he was like he had worked as a
graphic artist you know he that you see
that um album cover that's out there
pinned to the wall yeah that's him yeah
he drew that yeah she's drawn a few
amazing things I was very surprised
about that his a super versatile guy he
could do a lot of different things and
his work ethic was amazing like he would
have a binder and his scenes he would
have different color tabs for each scene
and he would go over his notes and go
over his lines like I'd never seen
anybody do it like none of us did
none of the rest of us did like the only
the only one who's like him like Steven
root was even more different than him
because Steven root was a character like
you played Jimmy James and he in real
life is like the sweetest most normal
guy but when he was playing that
character like he would become this
Jimmy James guy he was spooky like
you've seen him in a million like off
what is the movie no I stayed oh yes a
blur yeah nobody piece dude and he was
great in that new Western - what is it
The Ballad of Scruggs Buster Scruggs
what is it called
it's a Coen Brothers thing right isn't
it it's really weird
have you seen that no I haven't seen it
it's very weird it's very weird it's
really good but it's like whoa all right
just weird you know but but Stephen root
is in it's amazing
[Applause]